[Music]
Attendance
[Applause]
[Music] [
Applause] [
Music]
[Applause]
Participants listened to the report. The
report highlighted the notable achievements made by our Party and people in conflicting
periods and despite being overlooked in an environment of intense struggle.  It was a
summary of the problems faced when promoting the party's ecological environment protection project in a development-oriented manner in a prospective manner, the results achieved in the project to eliminate activities for economic development and improvement of people's lives, and the shortcomings that must be urgently overcome in the party's work.
In the report, we
benefited from the theory of the five great Danguns in the new era
[Applause]
[Music]
All
participants gathered
100 times more confidence and
united with one mind and one mind so that our noble ideology and sacred threat can ascend to the high stage of success and victory as soon as possible.  We are confident that we will be
able to take the lead in promoting comprehensive palace development with our stubborn dojo.